GILLIAN.
>> ALEXIS MCADAMS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S BRING IN TAMMY BRUCE, HOST
OF GET TAMMY BRUCE ON FOX NATION
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US THIS
MORNING.
YOU HEARD COLLEAGUE ALEXIS POINT
OUT FOX NEWS HAS REACHED OUT TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR
COMMENT ON THE MURDER, FOR
COMMENT ON HER POLICIES.
NO RESPONSE YET.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> IT IS HER JOB TO FIRST OF ALL
HELP MAKE THESE KINDS OF THINGS
NOT HAPPEN AND IF THEY DO, IT'S
THEN TO SHOW SOME LEADERSHIP.
THE FACT THAT SHE IS REFUSING TO
REMARK ON THIS TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT ALL THE DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS HAPPENING MULTI- STATES
AS WE KNOW IN THIS CASE.
EVEN THOSE CHARGES THAT WERE
DROPPED IN NEW YORK AGAINST THIS
GUY.
IF AT ANY STEP ACTUAL JUSTICE
WAS BEING IMPLEMENTED AND THIS
GUY WAS HELD IT WOULDN'T HAVE
HAPPENED.
THIS TRANSCENDS POLITICAL PARTY
OR RACE OR ECONOMY, TRANSCENDS
EVERYTHING.
IF YOU CAN'T WALK OUT OF A HOTEL
ROOM WITHOUT FEAR OF BEING
MURDERED IN THE LOBBY BY SOME
GUY SPRAYING BULLETS BECAUSE
IT'S AN ATTITUDE, ENVIRONMENT
AND CULTURE THAT GETS CREATED
WHEN THE BAD GUYS AND EVERYONE
ELSE SEES EVEN LEADERSHIP IS NOT
INTERESTED-IN-LAW AND ORDER AND
IF THEY ARE INTERESTED IT'S IN
ELIMINATING IT.
SO IT'S A GREEN LIGHT TO DO WHAT
YOU WANT.
THIS IS A GUY WHO FELT THAT HE
COULD DO THIS CLEARLY BECAUSE OF
HIS PAST EXPERIENCE WITHIN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WANDERING AROUND, GETTING
CAUGHT, BEING LET GO, CHARGES
DROPPED, NOBODY IS LOOKING FOR
HIM REALLY.
NOBODY IS REALLY CARING.
EVERYONE KNOWS THESE ARE
UNFORCED ERRORS AND HOCHUL'S
REFUSAL TO RESPOND MAKES IT
CLEAR.
SHE DOESN'T WANT TO UPSET THE
MARGINAL EXTREMISTS IN HER OWN
PARTY.
EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THE GRASSROOTS
HAS GOT TO SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE TO
ANY ONE IN ANY PARTY.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT EVERYONE,
THEIR OWN BASE CERTAINLY, TO BE
OBSESSED WITH ABORTION, RIGHT?
THIS IS THE ULTIMATE
DISTRACTION.
WHEN THIS IS GOING ON AND
POTENTIALLY IT DOESN'T MATTER,
YOU SEE IT IN NEW YORK CITY, WE
SEE IT HAPPENING TO NEW YORK
CITY, OLDER AND YOUNGER PEOPLE,
BLACK AND WHITE AND GAY AND
STRAIGHT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THIS IS AFFECTING ALL OF US.
OF COURSE, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A
DUTY, THEY ARE THE ONES WHO
CREATED THIS.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO CAN STOP
IT.
AND THE DEMOCRATS IN NOVEMBER
NEED TO SEND THEIR OWN STATEMENT
TO POLITICIANS THAT THIS HAS GOT
TO END.
>> THAT ELECTION 33 DAYS AWAY AS
OF TODAY.
I WANT TO TAKE YOUR TEMPERATURE
ON THIS AS WELL.
GEORGIA DEMOCRAT STACEY ABRAMS
STORY ABOUT THE 2018 ELECTION
WAS FULL OF TWISTS AND TURNS.
A FEDERAL JUDGE IS TOSSING A
LAWSUIT BY A GROUP THAT ABRAMS
IS TIED TO, THE SUIT POINTED 20
WHAT IT EFFECTIVELY SUGGESTS ARE
VOTER SUPPRESSION IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE WON BY KEMP.
ABRAMS DENIED SHE EVER
QUESTIONED KEMP'S VICTORY.
>> IS THERE ANY SCENARIO THAT
YOU WOULD CONCEDE YOU LOST
PUBLICLY IN 2018?
>> I HAVE NEVER DENIED THE
OUTCOME.
IT WAS NOT A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
I HAVE ONE CLEAR STATEMENT TO
MAKE.
WE WON.
IF IT LOOKS LIKE IT IS RIGGED IT
PROBABLY IS.
I DIDN'T LOSE.
I GOT THE VOTES.
>> AS THIS REMATCH PLAYS OUT
GOVERNOR KEMP WRITING TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS.
MS. ABRAMS CREATED A FALSE
NARRATIVE MUCH OF HER TARGET
AUDIENCE WAS WILLING TO ACCEPT
AND ECHO.
SHE IS SIDE STEPPING FACTS.
THE FEDERAL JUDGE EX BLOWSED HER
CLAIMS OF VOTER SUPPRESSION FOR
WHAT THEY ARE, FALSE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY, TAMMY?
>> YOU DESCRIBE IT AS A STORY.
FOR HER IT IS FICTION.
THESE ARE SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS.
IT IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT.
AT THE SAME TIME, IF YOU REALLY
BELIEVE THAT HAPPENED, THEN
STICK WITH IT, RIGHT?
THAT'S YOUR OWN BASIS OF
PRINCIPLES AND A STANDARD ABOUT
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO THE ELECTRIC
OR YACHT.
EVEN IF SHE REALLY BELIEVES THAT
HAPPENED.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE THE CHARACTER
TO STAND UP FOR WHAT SHE SAID
BEFORE BECAUSE NOW IT DOESN'T
SUIT A NARRATIVE.
WHAT ELSE WILL SHE LIE ABOUT OR
PRETEND ABOUT OR HAVE A
DIFFERENT STANDARD FOR BASED ON
WHERE THE WINDS BLOW?
WE CLEARLY ARE IN A TIME HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY WHERE LEADERSHIP IS
REQUIRED AND LEADERSHIP MEANS
TAKING POSITIONS, STANDING FOR
SOMETHING, REPRESENTING THINGS
THAT MATTER TO PEOPLE, NOT THE
THINGS THAT MATTER NECESSARILY
TO SOME MARGINAL PEOPLE IN YOUR
PARTY OR WHAT MOVES IN THE
MOMENT ABOUT WHAT MAY WORK IN
THE MOMENT.
THAT AMERICANS REALLY NEED
PEOPLE WHO STAND UP FOR THEM ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
STACEY ABRAMS IS FOR HERSELF AND
SAY WHATEVER IT TAKES.
YOU THINK MAYBE YOU CAN WALK ON
WATER.
ONE GUY IN HISTORY WAS ABLE TO
DO THAT.
YOU END UP FALLING.
THIS IS A PROBLEM FOR GEORGIANS.
AT LEAST WE'RE SEEING WHAT IT IS
SHE DOES NOT STAND FOR, WHICH IS
HONESTY.
>> MOST OF US MORTALS WILL END
UP FALLING.
>> EVERYONE EXCEPT O